time but we have a very exciting guest
in in in the house actually I'm Emily
IRA the associate curator at the world
chess Hall of Fame she was on the show
with us just a month ago at the Karen's
Cup and she's back and since then we
have another new exhibit at the world
chess all the fame us chests celebrating
80 years and she's with Maurice well
there's some fun jobs here at in st.
Louis whether it's at the Chess Club or
at the world chess Hall of Fame an Emily
Allred associate curator the world
treats all of Fame gets to have one of
the fun ones she gets to look at all
these new exhibits as they come through
tell us what your day-to-day role is
like what it's like to be the associate
curator of such a historic institution
it's it's different all the time so
right now we're we just finished the
u.s. chess a two years show we're
working on an upcoming show about MC
Escher and then we also are working on a
special project right now that's a
collaboration with another local museum
that is a chess themed golf hole so
there's not really it doesn't seem like
there's almost like a typical day we
just do a little bit of everything and
that keeps it fun absolutely always
variety is the spice of life tell us
about the exhibits that are there right
now first of all the older exhibit yeah
so we have two exhibits that will be up
through April 14th and on the first
floor we have Peter Mannion Universal
turf and that showcases the work of a
local artist named Peter Mannion and he
creates these beautiful kind of
immersive sculptures that are inspired
by the mind of a chess player during a
game and the second show that we have
right now is Harry Benson kings and
queens and so that show features
photography of Bobby Fischer and Fabiano
Caruana as well as a number of pop
culture stars everyone from like Queen
Latifah to the Williams sisters and so
it kind of shows how Harry Benson who's
a really well-known photographer you
know situated people like Bobby Fischer
among kind of these stars of pop culture
for actual royalty absolutely I can
world icons and now we have a new one
featuring chess here in the US the
history of chess here in the US
yeah so just not very long ago we opened
up a show called us chest 80 years and
you all contributed to it through a
video and so that celebrates the 80th
anniversary of the u.s. Chess Federation
and so we have everything from some of
the earliest newsletters it's a really
beautiful and amazing photography from
tournaments all around the country
everything from the high school
championships to the Austrian ships that
we're holding here today and we'll be
updating that show as the year goes on
so you know as history is being made
here in this competition we'll be
putting up the pictures of the new
champions and things like that in the
show you're not a chess player yourself
not a hardcore one anyway what is it
like to be so knowledgeable about this
field I mean you must know a lot more
than not only the average chess fan but
even grandmasters around the world so
one thing I've found since I started
working here is there are different
people who have different interests so
there are some people who are interested
you know only in playing there are some
people who are interested in both
playing and the history important
players and things like that and then
there are some people who are interested
only in kind of collecting so people who
collect chess sets so it's a really
interesting world to kind of be a part
of and you're learning new things all
the time because you know we do show is
not just about chess history but about
its intersections with art and popular
culture and so you know we get to do
everything from you know kind of what
you would expect chess history and the
inductions that we hold every year - you
know chess and superheroes speaking of
which you don't do events only for
adults you do a lot of events for
children as well yeah so every Tuesday
we have toddler Tuesdays and people can
bring their children in and we do
activities kind of inspired by the game
and then we also have adult activities
in the evenings which are art events
everything from earlier this week we had
to area making to you know painting that
kind of stuff and then we also have our
monthly music series and the composer
series and those are really popular they
almost always sell out and you can see
different musicians from the st. Louis
Symphony Orchestra so it's it's kind of
a unique opportunity for people great
job I could go over there sometimes
anyway tell us how folks can donate to
this great great work that you guys are
doing yeah so we our shows are only a
lot of times are made possible through
what artifacts we have that are donated
by people everyone from us and world
chess Hall of Famers to the average
chess fan and so if you're interested in
donating we collect everything from
chess chess sets representing popular
culture - you know score sheets from the
most famous players and if you're
interested in donating you can contact
info at Worlds chess Hof gorg to learn
more about that all right
don't donate like your old score sheets
from the games you lost the good stuff
thank you so much Emily keep up the
great work thank you